we're joined now by Donald Trump jr. I
think so much for coming on so what do
you think the lesson of impeachment is
other than obviously we owe Ukraine
everything we have but beyond that like
what's your take away from all this
well listen I think the obvious lesson
is that the do-nothing Democrats are
going to just do that
impeachment didn't even meet Nancy
Pelosi zone criteria when she set this
out a few months ago and the real
problem is the Democrats and Nancy are
so blinded by hate hatred of Donald
Trump
that they can't even function they
literally cannot do anything as they are
pushing the Russia hoax Donald Trump is
signing the u.s. MCA and getting that
done fixing NAFTA okay as they're
signing the articles of impeachment
Tucker he's signing a historic trade
deal with China he still goes on but
their hatred is making them make very
bad decisions the American people see it
they saw it up front and center last
night at the State of the Union where he
highlighted some incredible American
stories whether it be soldiers whether
it be just just great Americana and you
see them sitting there at night class
made me miserable well that's for sure
but yeah just back up for a second and
ask you the obvious political question
because this was a political process
with political goals they're not stupid
it was clear from day one that this was
likely to be counterproductive they
wanted to hurt the president they helped
him why did they do this because Nancy
Pelosi has been pushed into a corner by
the far left of her party right she's
not the brilliant tactician that
everyone says she is she's been bullied
by a progressive left that is absolutely
lost their minds but the American people
have not lost their way Tucker they get
it they have seen through the nonsense
they see that the impeachment hoax which
they've been pushing for three and a
half years now is just that it's a hoax
okay they couldn't do it with Russia
collusion this is just version 3.0 at
this point they've lost that battle the
American people want to see them getting
in there fixing maybe infrastructure we
have plenty of things that we could do
infrastructure would be a
one for my father because he's actually
a builder not a politician he would do
incredible things for America with that
but they could tackle drug pricing they
could tackle any number of things but
your viewers cannot name one thing that
they've even attempted to tackle other
than to resist Donald Trump and his
record of success well it's not even
interests it's not even a sort of
interesting mesh mission for a political
party I want to ask what the vote today
so let's say you devoted your life as a
you know as a businessman to buying
companies and then firing a lot of
people and offshoring a lot of the
company and you got rich doing that
whatever a lot of people do that private
equity fund but would you be in a
position to then deliver overwrought
moral lectures to others well no and the
the gentleman the senator who did that
it's sort of ironic when you look at
even his political career he's
flip-flopped for political expediency on
every major conservative issue that he
says he believes that now that he's in
Utah again just go look at the record
guys it speaks for himself whether it's
his track record on life the reality is
this he has come to Donald Trump for his
endorsement for money when he was
running he blew his chance Bigley and
he's so bitter about it that he cannot
let it go Tucker he cannot do the right
thing he cannot do what the people of
his state want he is purely like Nancy
Pelosi just blinded by hatred because
when he had his shot he couldn't do it
and he's more concerned about attempting
to be loved by those who hate his guts
by the media by the left who destroyed
his political career who destroyed his
presidential run then he is about doing
what his constituency actually wants and
it's become now so transparent that you
can't even hide from it he's not brave
he's a coward I just think it's funny
that people who are so angry feel the
need rather just be angry I don't like
you I'm doing this feel the need to give
you a lecture about how good they are as
people know what wonderful guy just look
at the record speaks for itself thanks
so much for joining great to be with you